ce hit
va à vous Mr Wick
[Musique]
Ed 42 régulier n'est-ce pas ouais
And So It Begins
c'est
[Applaudissements] [
Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce modèle
responsable étranger
étant français je dois commencer par ça
comment  c'était amusant d'être présidentiel totalement trash
et l'étape
était vraiment quelque chose de très très
spécial et
je ne pouvais pas imaginer dans mes rêves les plus fous
filmer John Wick dans les escaliers en face
de Sacramento ou filmer
devant Sacramento pour être vous savez  dans le
labeur en plastique et
être dans la rue à filmer des scènes de voiture
et des poursuites et
euh il y a vraiment quelque chose de vraiment
spécial
ouais et bien le problème c'est que je viens de
recevoir un message d'Anita va la maire
de Paris et euh tu es Ben de Paris
tu  je ne peux pas conduire une voiture à Paris, tu peux
non, je plaisante, je plaisante, nous t'aimons,
le premier était amusant, le deuxième était
utilisé, le troisième était épique, je ne
sais même pas comment appeler celui-ci, je veux dire
C'est bizarre comme
je l'ai trouvé parfois avec les gens, tu peux
juste dire John avec
tu sais ce que je veux dire et toi et toi
et tu comprends tu sais c'est
bien, comment c'était, c'est John Wick
tu sais et donc c'est comme de l'action  le
look Le monde l'humour le drame le
pathétique l'idée c'est presque comme une façon
de dire
John Wick et tu comprends je veux
dire c'est un phénomène comment
expliquez-vous cela comment expliquer que c'est
devenu si grand
je ne le fais pas  je sais, j'espère que c'est parce que nous avons
fait un très bon film, je
dirais que 99 d'entre eux sont Keanu Reeves et un
pour cent de sa chance donc je vais y aller, tu sais que
nous avons fait de bons films qui
sont amusants,
tu sais, je pense que tu peux juste
Immergez-vous dans ce monde, l'un de mes
réalisateurs préférés est Bob Fosse et il a
toujours dit que 50% de la réalisation consistait à trouver
des idées folles et que les 50 autres consistaient à
trouver des gens plus fous que vous pour les
exécuter,
donc je vais y aller avec ça.  j'avais
des acteurs et une équipe très formidables pour
m'aider à exécuter ouais personnellement, je pense que ce
sont de très bons films, vous savez, il y
a aussi le fait que vous
respectez les références, je veux dire, bien sûr, vous citez des
jeux, des films d'arts martiaux,
je vous connais.  Je suis un grand fan de ça, tu
cite aussi beaucoup de choses mais tu fais
ça avec respect, c'est si important pour
toi ouais absolument c'est en fait l'un
des grands plaisirs, je veux dire, Chad Sahelski
aime le cinéma, j'aime le cinéma
euh et qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pour toi  sais que c'est
l'esthétique c'est la technique
tu connais le drame de la caméra tu
connais les perspectives et puis que
mets-tu devant cette caméra
quelle est l'histoire que tu racontes quelle est
la synthèse quelle est l'unité
quelle est la perspective
et  en regardant tous les maîtres des
genres qui nous inspirent pour
voir cela, mais ensuite pour traduire là où
vous pouvez en avoir une idée. Je suis
fasciné par le cinéma asiatique. Je suis
fasciné par les vieux westerns, que ce soit
John Ford ou  Sergio Leone un film
avec lequel j'ai grandi était The Warriors de Walter Hill
et tu aimes les mangas tu aimes les anime tu
aimes les films wuja One Car Wise zangimo
Troy Hawk Jackie Chan Jet Lee Donnie Yen
Je veux dire Samo a accroché d'énormes influences tu
sais hiroyuki uh hiroyuki Sonata toi  Je
connais Kurosawa, vous connaissez Sunny Chiba, de
Lee Marvin à Steve McQueen en passant par Clint
Eastwood, je veux dire ceux que j'essaie juste de
mettre cela dans le John Wicks de toutes les
choses que j'aime dans le cinéma ou les
idées que je reçois en m'inspirant des
œuvres des autres.  mais ensuite vous
créez aussi votre propre truc, la seule façon pour John
Wick d'avoir à nouveau la liberté
et la paix
ouais pas vraiment le personnage lui-même l'
aspect nihiliste mélancolique du
personnage pensez-vous que c'est pertinent
pour l'époque dans laquelle nous vivons peut-être aussi non
ouais mais  Je pense que c'est comme
et puis peut-être que c'est là que nous entrons dans
le cinéma et l'archétype, vous
savez et je pense que John Wick
touche un archétype et euh
vous connaissez les lunaires, le lunaire, The
Loner, vous connaissez quelqu'un qui cherche du
changement, vous savez, il cherche  la liberté, en fin
de compte, cherche quelque temps à changer
son monde et peut-être qu'en changeant son
expérience, il change les autres
dans cette marche et peut-être, espérons-le, même
son sacrifice pour nous amener à
quelque chose de meilleur ou de différent ou de toute façon,
donc je pense que c'est archétypal
et c'est tellement amusant
Mercy  Semaine de Jean